[Musica]
[Applauso]
entro anni li accompagnerò piano piano
in un mondo magico nel mondo alla
montagna un mondo bellissimo fantastico
facciamo un test dove per vivere quel
mondo bisogna essere assolutamente
connessi sommato connesso
fondamentalmente vivo in valtellina in
un luogo magico dove la montagna abbiamo
nella nel sangue
e proprio qui stavo vedendo l'immagine
del k2 con la montagna che ho sempre
sognato fin da piccolino perché uno dei
primi salitori sul k2 achille compagnoni
nel 54 tutti gli anni il 31 luglio in
valfurva raccontava la sua salita
io mi sono innamorato della montagna mi
sono innamorato di con la montagna
perfetta il k2 il k2 la montagna degli
italiani è la seconda montagna più alta
del mondo con gli 8.611 metri il k2 lo
salito il primo agosto del 2008 senza
ossigeno
lassù o bivaccato a 8.400 metri perché
la mia connessione con la montagna non
c'era più c'era qualcosa non funzionava
c'è qualcosa che non andava bene mi son
fermato o bivaccato e poi ho ritrovato
la connessione per continuare
ho passato una notte a 8.400 metri senza
cibo senza tenda sacco a pelo senza
niente e mi son dovuto connettere
perfettamente alla montagna per riuscire
a stare sveglio per non morire perché là
sopra a quelle quote dopo aver salito il
k2 senza ossigeno è semplice perde la
connessione è semplice lasciarsi andare
ed è semplice morire o bivaccato su
quella montagna la montagna difficile
una montagna tecnicamente non semplice
da affrontare una montagna che per
salirla devi essere molto allenato e
preparato con la montagna
mi ha lasciato il dono più prezioso che
tutti noi abbiamo la vita dopo che il
bivacco purtroppo sono morte quella
notte sono morte 11 persone sono scese
della montagna con dei grossi problemi
problemi legati al congelamento scalare
su quelle montagne non è assolutamente
semplice bisogna essere precisi allenati
avere conoscenza e se determinati per
raggiungere la cima di questa montagna
di queste montagne per scalare non solo
le montagne dell'himalaya ma tutte le
montagne per affrontare il mio mondo che
al mondo particolare il mondo di una
guida alpina denis ma la lista di un
formatore di un elisoccorso tore ea
volte oggi definirmi un creatore di
sogni sorrisi bisogna essere connessi
sempre sempre una vita e una connessione
fondamentalmente ma la bisogna essere
molto molto attenti ad essere tutto
questo è una montagna difficile da
affrontare non semplice il continuare
dal campo base andava sul campo 1
dormire poi campo 2 poi ridiscende al
campo base riposare poi tornare su al
campo 1 campo 2 campo 3 dormire poi
tornare giù al campo base
questo è l'acclimatamento il clima
tamento serve per stressare il corpo
umano per riuscire a mettere in atto una
variazione a livello di sangue di
ematocrito di gobbo i rossi per far sì
che il nostro corpo riesca a salire la
sopra dove manca l'ossigeno e per andare
in vetta in questo caso al k2 il primo
agosto del 2008 rimetta la mia montagna
il mio sogno il k2 la discesa è stata
purtroppo tragica con la notte sono
morte 11 persone per lunga permanenza in
quota si è rimasto ben tre giorni sopra
gli 8.000 metri dopo il bivacco
i miei piedi sono congelati
e questa una difesa del corpo umano
perché al corpo ma è una macchina
perfetta e dopo che congelamento mi è
cambiata completamente la vita
io sono imputato a me mancano dieci dita
dei piedi
io ho perso una connessione editori
aprirne un'altra
ho dovuto imparare a camminare
non è stato semplice assolutamente non è
semplice affrontare un imputazione per
un alpinista che tra virgolette lavoro
con i piedi
gli alpinisti scalano e arrampicano
siano con i piedi e con le mani perdere
una parte del tuo corpo in questo caso
10 dei piedi è un problema un alpinista
correre sciare arrampicare scalare è un
problema senza di te i piedi da un certo
punto quando mi hanno accompagnato sul
padova dove c'è un medico preparatissimo
su questo o medico un chirurgo vascolare
che mi ha curato mi ha preso nelle sue
le sue braccia come un bambino e piano
piano mi ha fatto ritornare nel mio
mondo ma per trovare il mio mondo non è
stato semplice di un certo punto dopo
l'amputazione
ho staccato tutto non era più connesso
quel mondo fuori di me attuale non c'era
più nessuno pensavo solo a me stesso
studentato automaticamente egoista
pensavo solo a me solo a me solo la mia
vita ai miei piedi
i miei piedi e automaticamente con
questa pedicure pesa in tre stati corti
corti corte però con tanta forza di
volontà di fatto gli home io che non ero
neanche mio per un mio pensiero
no pain no gain se non soffre non non
raggiungerà gli obiettivi sono tornato
dopo un anno ho imparato a camminare è
chiaro piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano sono tornato a 8.000 metri
con tanto tanto tanto allenamento però è
la connessione è una cosa scontata è
semplice e facile il mio corpo il mio
brain e sempre connesso mi son sempre
connesso io vivo e lavoro fuori
dall'area confort non esiste per melara
confort tutti i giorni o cambia qualcosa
sia come guida alpina che come tecnico
di soccorso come maestri di sci come ma
la lista cambia sempre tutto per me è
semplice mi son sempre costantemente
connesso la vita fondamentalmente la
connessione perché
pensateci così la vita la connessione
questa è tanto il mio mestiere
questo è il soccorso di soccorso
come ho detto prima questo il soccorso a
di tissi mo che abbiamo effettuato nel
2017 al d'aula giri dove abbiamo salvato
sette alpinisti dell'esercito indiano in
questo particolare soccorso
la comunicazione
fiducia e responsabilità la conoscenza
la connessione è stata fondamentale per
riuscire a portare a casa sette persone
che stanno per morire la sopra perché
dopo aver salito il d'aula giri han
finito l'ossigeno me lo scempio scendere
sul campo base e andavano verso i danni
celebrali polmonari congelamenti siamo
riusciti a portare a casa uno staff di
italiani due piloti del soccorso
trentino con un tecnico del soccorso
valtellinese dobbiamo agganciati 1x1
abbiamo da tutti a casa questa di malaja
questa è la montagna vede benissimo che
in montagna per luogo magico bellissimo
non va assolutamente sottovalutato
bisogna sempre essere connesse una
parrocchia
penso che a tanti suonerà ancora
risuonerà nella mente nei pensieri ma
questa è commissione essere sempre
preparati sempre essere attenti e anche
essere connessi proprio con l'effetto
natura con la montagna montagna mare
effetto natura la forza non siamo noi la
forza e quella l'effetto natura che il
mare e la montagna
qui stiamo scalando stiamo scalando
traverso il campo 2 del manaslu che è il
mio primo ottomila dopo l'amputazione
io dedicato al carissimo amico marco
simoncelli che purtroppo se n'è andato
quell ottomila per lui la sopra per me è
stato un qualcosa di grandioso il mio
primo 8.000 dopo dopo l'amputazione una
produzione importante per un alpinista
perché come detto in precedenza con un
alpinista scalare arrampicare sia con
tan tan tissimo i piedi i nostri sono
dei sensori fondamentalmente non aver
quello cambia tutto automaticamente
cambia una connessione e se ne trova
all'altra
volere è potere capito che l'importanza
la resilienza di tenere sempre duro di
mai mollare e vi è sempre chiaro un
obiettivo parlo tantissimo ai bambini
parlo tantissimo le l'aziendale questa
la resilienza avere sempre chiare un
obiettivo è mai mollare ai bambini
insegno ai quattro comandamenti che sono
obbedire studiare fare sport e mai
mollare e sognare deve essere un dovere
e con loro mi connetto sempre è
importante loro sono nostro futuro
questa e resilienza che di avere un
alpinista sugli 8mila si sale si dorme
in quota e si scende si riposa un
pochettino al campo base poi si torna su
siri traccia né essere resistenti avere
conoscenza per capire dove si sta
andando
è importante lo studio è importante
capitolo si va e sempre essere connessi
alla montagna alla natura capire
sentirla questa connessione per me
questo è manaslu il mio prima il mio
primo ottomila anche salito dopo proprio
imputazione l'importazione importante
che non mi ha fermato perché tanti hanno
creduto che marco fosse finito marco sta
continuando sta condannando perché sto
cercando di ragioni questo grande sogno
che il raggiungimento di tutte le cime
delle 14 montagne più alte del mondo
la corona dagli 8.000 un progetto molto
ambizioso e ambito degli alpinisti non
semplice da raggiungere con molti che
poi ti porta logicamente a tanti
sacrifici
questo è un campo base
siamo sempre al ma naso capite che per
riuscire a fare certe cose devi sempre
avere una lucidità tale frase sempre
preciso di aver sempre il tuo obiettivo
sapere fin dove si può usare e quando si
torna indietro
scrivo mi piace scrivere
ho aumentato un gioco per riuscire a far
capire le persone al di fuori del mio
mondo cosa vuol dire alla montagna la
montagna e magia con la montagna sa
anche essere spietata per riuscire a far
capire le persone fin dove si può andare
mi piace scrivere in questo caso mi è
stato un gioco un gioco scatola sfida
gli 8.000 che insegna le regole base per
via da montagna di insicurezza
qui sono sempre sulla montagna stiamo
salendo verso il campo 3 con la sopra la
vetta del manaslu il mio prima il mio
più 8.000 proprio votazione
stiamo vedendo questi blocchi di
ghiaccio che sono una valanga che
purtroppo a caso di problemi sul nostro
percorso di salita ma che poi piano
piano sempre con tanta determinazione
abbiamo ritracciato la salita verso il
campo 3 nel campo 4 per poi salire lassù
dove il mondo e rotondo per caso e
vedrete quando sbuca dalla cresta la
sfericità della terra la sopra se
talmente in alto che il mondo si vede
rotondo e non è l'effetto ottico per sé
talmente in alto pensate a 8.167 metri
ed è talmente lontano che il mondo è
sferico e rotondo certo non servì a che
conforto andasse lassù per farlo capire
ma il mondo è rotondo qui siamo al campo
4 e qui siamo in vetta è un pianto
liberatorio
l'impianto di soddisfazione personale
perché sono tornato lassù dopo che
abbiamo è successo un pianto per marco
per il mio caro amico marco e per questa
bellezza questo non lacrime di felicità
e di tristezza
io dico sempre che marco è una persona
che le mani grandi e forti ma con un
cuore molto delicato come detto prima ho
già definirmi creatore di sogni e
sorrisi
è vero
la delicatezza di una persona che questa
è una persona deve saper piangere ed è
importante piangere e qui siamo in vetta
guardate fate la sfericità della terra è
una cosa magica perché là sopra gli
alpinisti ma la iss t che salgono la
somma senza ossigeno sono degli eletti
noi saremo là sopra senza niente vediamo
il mondo diversamente questo è il mondo
che vedono un alpinista ma la lista
dalla su 8.167 metri luogo magico questa
questa finale mancano 100 metri si
esultava sopra perché là sopra si esulta
si esulta l'arrivo di questa di questo
grande obiettivo dopo due mesi di
sacrifici ma poi dico sempre io spengo
un computer né attacco un altro perché
il difficile tornare a casa vivi con un
raggiunge la montagna è a metà
dell'opera
bisogna ancora scendere per cui
disconnette riconnettono altra cosa stai
facendo un computer e si scende la
social campo base
ma de vinco ad avere benzina per tornare
a casa per scendere vivo perché il dono
più importante che tutti noi abbiamo in
questa sala ricordate sempre solo e
resterà semplici solo uno la vita tutto
resto non conta niente
qui si scende adesso
si scende verso il campo base con tanta
felicità
logicamente con tanto allenamento
possibile fare anche questo campo 4betta
campo base tutto questo è il mio mondo
la mia vita io vivo per la montagna che
ultimamente sta entrando quasi una
missione perché parlo tantissimo i
giovani il futuro del mondo
parlo tantissimo alle aziende porto la
mia esperienza di ma la lista è dimesso
di sì il tecnico di soccorso di creatori
sono i sorrisi nelle aziende per
riuscire a fargli capire effettivamente
come funziona il mio mondo come il palo
e problem solving
io sorrido sorrido perché nel mio mondo
velocemente bisogna risolvere i problemi
ma per i soliti problemi bisogna essere
connessi
ma se preparati bisognava fiducia
responsabilità mai mollare
tant è che queste cose questo è il mio
mondo questa non è una che mi ha
accompagnato quel giorno per scendere
fino al campo base del manaslu in
giornata la felicità di riuscire a
tornare lassù nel mondo e questo è un
altro mondo che mi appartiene
io amo i giovani amo i bambini dopo il
disastroso terremoto dal 2015 il 25
aprile del 2015
in nepal con degli amici abbiamo
ricostruito una scuola per i bambini
perché i bambini nepal vorrebbero due
cose sono due cose mangiare e studiare
mangiare e studiare e noi italiani sono
usciti a fare anche questo
ricostruire la scuola per i bambini
della del nepal le membra no pain no
gain
grazie
[Applauso]